Kamala Harris she just gave a speech
in which she she committed a gaffe and a
gaff most people think a gaff is when a
politician accidentally says something
that he doesn't mean to say
a gaff is actually when a politician act
accidentally tells the truth and that's
what happened here when Kamala Harris
accidentally articulated the ultimate
goal of so many leftist policies
think about the impact on something like
public health
when we invest in clean energy and
electric vehicles and reduce population
more of our children can breathe clean
air and drink clean water
[Applause]
what was that
hold on oh I said we were going to drink
clean air and have no no before that oh
we're gonna have clean water no hold on
I think it was after that where was the
can we play that again please think
about the impact on something like
public health
when we invest in clean energy and
electric vehicles and reduce population
okay there we go we got it we got it
reduce population
she opens up she says think about the
effect on public health
and then
as part of Public Health she suggests we
reduce the population
reducing the population means killing
people
or at the very the most charitable way
you could read that is
sterilizing people getting people not to
have kids whether physically or just
culturally
that's what they want they really do
want to reduce the population and
they've they've said it sometimes
overtly sometimes only implicitly this
has been true since Margaret Sanger in
the birth control movement
it's been true since the the most
radical forms of liberalism and it's
really been true since the Garden of
Eden because the devil and the
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places that controls
this world really doesn't like people
and so all these left-wing policies
keep coming down to this same point
which is reducing population which is
killing human beings isn't that weird
shouldn't that make you scratch your
head if you're a liberal
you say wait all of these all of these
policies abortion the encouragement of
deviant sexual behaviors
sterilization
euthanasia so-called the Planned
Parenthood contraception on and on and
on
all for for supposedly different
purposes for women's freedom for climate
protection for compassion for the
elderly and the sick for this for that
they totally change the justification
but the end result is always the same
killing people
shouldn't that give you pause you say
hold on
the Practical effect of all of my
policies is killing people no matter
what the justification is
maybe we're the baddies maybe are we
potentially the Baddies
when you look around the world and you
say wow
the vast majority of the world doesn't
kill anywhere near as many babies as we
do and they don't permit killing babies
as late in the game as we do
that in fact the countries are the most
radical abortion policies are America
Canada sorry to say
China and North Korea which are not
great regimes so are we are we the
baddies are we on the wrong side of this
issue Russia which is a place with all
sorts of problems that has done all
sorts of bad things
they're not
they're actually Banning that we're
promoting that are we on this particular
issue are we perhaps the baddies are we
if our motivating
drive here
is to
reduce the population
and the whole point of statecraft is so
that people can flourish it's to pursue
the good and to avoid evil and to allow
people to live happy lives which is
articulated in our
Declaration of Independence life liberty
and sometimes the classical liberals
they'll they want to rewrite the
Declaration of Independence as John
Locke articulated this phrase and
they'll say that we're here for life
liberty and property that's that's not
it that's not what Jefferson wrote
that's not what the founding fathers
wrote they said life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness which refers to a
more classical conception of statecraft
which is the common good
what is law the classical conception of
the law is the law is an ordinance of
reason for the common good by him who
has care of the community and
promulgated
it's not good to kill people it doesn't
that doesn't help people's good and
that's what they want right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles balance of nature fruits and
veggies are a great way to make sure you
are getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day for balance
of Nature's Advanced cold vacuum process
the vitamins minerals and phytonutrients
of the fruits and veggies are preserved
so that you can get that vital nutrition
in each capsule balance of nature is a
whole food supplement with no additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
or added sugar pure fruits and veggies
are the only things they put in their
capsules I love this
I love this
more I think than even these Jackal
hyenas around the daily wire who go and
they rip it all and they take it all
away when we get a delivery to the Daily
wire before even yours truly can get his
hands on any balance of nature send a
bunch of their products down here you
know how that works out with these with
these animals I got to get I got to get
there faster reap all kinds of benefits
when you check it out your body will
thank you for a limited time this summer
when you become a preferred customer
balance of nature they're throwing in a
free fruit and veggies travel set and
giving an additional 25 bucks off your
first order go to balanceofnature.com
use promo code Knolls for a free travel
set and 25 bucks off your first order as
a preferred customer balanceofnature.com
promo code Knowles some GOP
establishment types are insisting that
this Ukraine issue it's not a big deal
it's not really going to affect the way
that people vote in 2024 Americans vote
on domestic policy not on foreign policy
come on get out of here move along well
this is a lot more than just an academic
question because the war in Ukraine is
heating up the Biden Administration is
becoming more belligerent in Ukraine and
now Joe Biden is calling up reservists
potentially to fight the war in Ukraine
so it's no longer just we're going to
send some tanks and guns over there to
Ukraine and the ukrainians can defend
their own country increasingly you're
seeing the normalization of talks that
American servicemen will be fighting
against Russians in Ukraine which
strikes me as completely insane but
that's what the Biden Administration is
doing
Biden just said just declared I'll read
the exact language
by The Authority invested in me as
president by the Constitution the laws
of the United States including sections
121 and 12 304 of title 10 U.S code I
hereby determine that it is necessary to
augment the active armed forces of the
United States for the effective conduct
of operation Atlantic resolve in and
around the United States European
command's area of responsibility that's
a lot of jargon that's a lot of
gobbledygook what does it mean it means
that we are further preparing the U.S
military to participate in something
called operation Atlantic resolve what
is Operation Atlantic resolve that
started in 2014 and it in fact I have
friends who were part of it it bolstered
the U.S military presence in the wake of
Russia's invasion of Crimea in 2014 so
this is during the the Obama
Administration this goes back a long
ways and so you might say well the war
in Ukraine is increasingly unpopular now
in the year of Our Lord 2023. that's
true but the war in Ukraine didn't start
a year ago the war in Ukraine didn't
start even two years ago
the war in Ukraine
has been building and American
participation in that war has been
building for almost a decade now
2014.
this is a long time coming the CIA
director was Landing in Kiev almost a
decade ago after the color Revolution
After the maidan Revolution that kicked
out a pro-russian leader in Ukraine and
installed a more pro-western leader in
Ukraine so the the participation has
been much more long-standing than a lot
of people know and the stakes are much
higher here we're we're bought in on
Ukraine forget the bazillions of dollars
that we've given to Ukraine over the
last two years and so there is no hold
up from the dod and from the liberal
establishment to increase the the
tensions in that war that's why Tucker
Carlson is saying hey if the Democrats
already bought in on fighting Ukraine
and half the Republicans already bought
in on that I'm going to stand up here I
want to hold people's feet to the fire
and call attention to this war before it
spins totally out of control boy what a
great clip that was make sure you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show
we'll see you next time